these guys are like the top five percent
of men and it's not just
you know these four quadrants that exist
like you can have overlap over here um i
don't have a way to do it with this
cursor on this grid right now because
i'm not on my
quadrant sheet that i was working on but
if i could put like a big oval over a
certain area i mean you could actually
encompass two sometimes three of these
different areas because somebody
couldn't encompass more than one trait
they could have a dominant unplugged
alpha trait with some plugged in
characteristics as well if you follow
what i'm saying but generally speaking
the unplugged alphas
amount for about the top five percent of
men it's like the top one to five
percent of men
some are naturals very very few of them
are naturals in fact but some are
naturals meaning like they were they're
just that way like they were red pilled
from their childhood they've always been
that way they've always been the chads
they've always been unplugged they don't
get you know uh goose by
or lied to by anybody they can see the
code in the matrix they're just naturals
in that sense they live mental point of
origin and chase excellence not women
okay
men want to be them women want to be
with them this is incredibly important
this is an incredibly important
distinction from many of the other
categories because it's only when you
achieve this level
that you that you know like when you
know then you know sort of thing
um they are significant and are
excellent problem solvers they don't
sulk they don't moan they don't whine
and complain about life circumstances
they find a way to remedy where they're
at if if they're not happy with where
they're at in their life
they work on it they find a solution
when i'm talking about significance
it's like social status okay
you're not going to get a lot of
unplugged alphas very very few in fact
in fact they're probably almost absent
completely
most of them have
a significant stance somewhere in the
world maybe they're a person of
influence a person of notoriety
they generally have
if they're on social media they have a
strong supportive following you know you
get my point what i'm saying like they
have some significance they have social
proof
okay
another point that i've put under the
unplugged alpha category is they have
achieved
physical conditioning peak physical
conditioning they they've achieved the
golden ratio the 1.62 shoulder-to-hip
ratio that we know women admire and love
and this is not me making it up oh rich
you know this is not you just no this is
this is evolutionary psychology it's
been covered in many many research
papers and studies
broad shoulders narrow ways chicks dig
it's as simple as that unplug alphas
almost always have it you're not going
to find a lot of guys in this category
that are completely unplugged are alphas
and are out of shape it just does not
exist
they're outcome independent
and sorry the outcome independent to
results that they get in life so if
things go their way great
if things don't go their way they look
for the silver lining and the lesson and
they move on they don't lose they learn
okay
they they generally are or are becoming
and i'm going to zoom in on this word
over here anti-fragile
okay and what that means is if you're
going to take i was talking about
fragility before if you're going to take
a box
and you fill it with i don't know like
some you know ceramic mugs like this
let's say which you can get in the merch
store on my youtube channel the store
tab
and you drop it they're all gonna break
okay because they're fragile you put a
bag of sand in a cardboard box and you
drop it you can mark that robust because
it doesn't change it doesn't it doesn't
get worse it doesn't get better it just
stays the same it's a bag of sand
anti-fragility essentially means when
you add chaos to it it becomes better it
actually becomes
a better version of what it was before
okay
there's there's not much that i could
you know put in a box and say oh you
know if i put this pen or this this set
of headphones or a spoon in the box it's
anti-fragile you get the point though
but guys that are unplugged alphas
generally are or are becoming
anti-fragile because they understand the
importance of that
when they see the writing on the wall
when they see what's going on in society
when they see the control the mainstream
media when they see what the state is
doing with mass and lockdowns and you
know all this manufactured indignation
that we're living in today they
they lean into the future and they make
plans to protect themselves so they have
anti-fragility as things change and
escalate okay that's a very important
component of the unplugged alpha it's
something that i'm going to spend some
more time talking about in my follow-up
book to the first one
so you can look forward to reading about
that soon
they generally have accumulated or are
accumulated seven figure plus wealth
seven eight figure plus wealth these
guys are not poor okay unplugged alphas
have figured out how to make it rain
they
they don't do it for girls they don't do
it to show off flashy cars or anything
like that they do it because they
recognize the importance of having
options and why money is important and
how that solves problems okay
only women allow sorry uh the next point
only allow women into their life if they
are a compliment not the focus and they
spot problem women fast and they get rid
of them
very important part of all this
another component of the unplugged alpha
is they will never be the smartest guy
in the room there's times where they
might find themselves in a room where
they are the smartest guy maybe they're
on stage given a lecture or the
presentation or something like that
they're being paid for their time for
example but they don't intentionally
spend time in rooms where they look
around and they go wow i'm the brightest
guy here let's keep doing this for days
and weeks and months and years on end
when they recognize that they're in the
room where they are the most calibrated
socially
perfected in the way that they interact
and where they go in life then they're
just like okay well i've learned
everything that i can from this room i
need to put myself in more challenging
rooms they also understand that their
network is their net worth
people that are unplugged alphas they
have phenomenal networks you could strip
them of everything they ever get in
their lives their money their wealth
their cars their their housing their
properties the real estate the women you
could strip them of all of that
and then drop them in a foreign country
as long as they have their phone and
their contacts you will see them solve
problems that plugged in betas could
never touch
network is their net worth they
understand the importance of that
and last but not least they surround
themselves with winners and remove
losers quickly
you